is that vegan cake you know I bet you
taste just like a regular cake - yeah I
probably tastes better than but how are
you a vegan and I bet you'd buy
healthier what parts can even welcome to
the pre birthday party podcast we got
Rene Garcia all the way from Houston
Texas and I wanna live now in the valley
and Van Nuys probably right now North
Hollywood North Hollywood same [ __ ]
borderline Van Nuys Sherman Oaks know
how much a razor on all the way from
Hawaii Hilo time in the world
hey guys through the tour is here the
big hair faith calls us Eddie the big
hair fake co-host
what's a G what's going on so bad in
Santa Barbara last week we got the
hecklers of our hecklers sitting on top
bro you could talk about the level or
don't like at first it was like ha and
then like then a fella to show started
again you know I said everybody was
laughing again and they were like I
don't know what's going on then some
foods that kicked out some food we're
asking a man now they just saw Santa
Barbara but this is funny bad now Johnny
rocky was there when they were doing the
man Johnny here Dee Joaquin's with all
the old for fools broke
and the foods that I wear leather gloves
to cut [ __ ] you take it dawg
oh my gosh you're pulling your ticket in
Lord to do bro dude they're like beyond
I'm gonna take it on their phone and
like I was trying to break the phone
rope and they take it
they're like Henny Youngman no gold old
blog and it's not only were like Johnny
rockin said that out they were having a
secure you were there now I'm telling
them he's gonna be a Latino audience so
they're not used to being in theaters he
heard it the week before so he [ __ ]
he heard that but these old people that
have no man people were like loud and
they're kicking fools out and there's
the people are asking us should we go to
the front closer cuz see people here are
loud which I don't watch the show and
then they were gonna even or two days
later oh you didn't a man to post a full
name Jacob Flores buddy from Santa
Barbara he said that uh email a little
food that got kicked out dogs my whole
we got low today and they kicked him out
but um see man our security guards as I
remember I used to theater crowns bro
like yeah [ __ ] you know the Nutcracker
who raised his boys they call it cops
the cops showed up at the show yeah it's
a theater they want you to the balcony a
kicked out gently like I said I don't
punch nobody yeah we say you did you
just go up there bro dude it was just
starting dog it started like at the end
I said well the one [ __ ] came in just
drunk as [ __ ]
see what a Toby's thing you like he said
ah man these people are wild people
showed up
Oh [ __ ] they showed up drawer
tailgating in the biking that rock just
like beyond annoying drunk and you know
like probably got drunkards they [ __ ]
walked up there yeah Jim people together
bro at a happy hour getting [ __ ] up
having dinner and then go to your show
and then getting in line bro we probably
good for seats to you by being there
while walking off pigeon toed dog just
you know there was an usher in a
wheelchair you know that how do you roll
up the [ __ ] you know the aisles man
that's hard that was left with just a
baby fish say they keep it noise daddy
that was it or what homie go ship dog oh
you've heard that stupid ass young yeah
the guy he said I got six months to live
couldn't play the bill he gave me
another six months
I used to be no today was a lot during
the Depression what happened I used to
be an usher at the movie theater for the
longest do it we had where we went with
transition for my tickets who didn't
know name it we went from like regular
films to [ __ ] on uh DVDs that was
crazy but it was I don't know if I talk
about like the the general manager
yeah theater do the managers they're
shady because they will go inside the
theaters with their own trash can to
pick up like all the plastic cups go in
the back wash them and resell them to
for the money huh the cash bro they got
Kyle's now so true bro yeah
the stadium understand we've got the
club's wrong uh-huh
and then at the end of the night we're
short like a little bit of money and
then somebody acoustic up see sunset
room the big remember oh yeah they're
[ __ ] hope her husband was like a
crazy looking dude
Oh or not the big chooses Jan and John
huh John and Jen yeah not in general no
no these to come yeah I know those two
that's done it gently their work
somewhere else but do I remember
cleaning the [ __ ] in the movie theater
and then like these two guys it was like
two uh Lebanese guys they come in and
over to me they start put on the stomach
side and leave dude no way to save money
bro yeah vegan latina our way Sevilla
vegan Latina bake dude it is and I'm not
vegan buy any partner that is delicious
I think I might become vegan I don't
know oh my god okay I don't want to get
out of hand hold on a second do you
recommend that's dope bro give out mm
dude this guy that's on you look like a
little girl you're actually Stein you
look like a little boy now bro you're
growing up - you started in Houston
right don't be a real got you started
right well yeah I started together well
you know no he was already I know he
started at the laughs table with big
Pete yeah man you big baby school huh a
cloak on a laptop
mm-hmm and it was run by a guy named
Mark Babbitt at first when I do was good
to that dude was the only guy that ever
booked me for a show
cancelled it and still send me one her
percent of the money dawg is that right
dude I couldn't believe it but then I
but you know but they don't [ __ ] happen
to other people that's my story
everybody's a different story amen and
now that's my story I was taking with it
and I will bring me to do like crazy ass
shows brother wouldn't even exist
day okay we were the one show were like
Joe Diaz get requests yes my cell
[ __ ] free Soto and Freddie saw a man
it was bad now were the first time it
was my willy work with Joe Diaz with
mark Babbitt and like it did a little
run right and it was just them - yeah he
has just met around but every new Joe
Diaz like from just knowing him right
and we had we had like rapport ready
yeah and we didn't know right really
worth it was all how they let you know
it's time to the the the promoter hey my
brother your legend and oh pasta but
this is but why will you know I'm saying
yeah look at those [ __ ] shoes dude I
met Joey Diaz way before I met Willy and
I I remember meeting Joey there at the
left stop man and and I I was like who
the hell is this guy
he's got great clothes I don't like I
mean I don't even know if they're
[ __ ] but he called me man seriously
and and he's been like that long as I've
known him bro that's why everybody every
time somebody asked me about Joey Diaz
like dude man is that stuff he says like
for real I go amen
I go dude I go Joey's telling you
telling you for a reason you know and
probably a hundred percent it's true I
go but even if it's [ __ ] bro I go it
don't you believe it anyway yeah I did I
know I did and this is like back in 97
98 bro what happened when you met Willy
put your headlock or uh oh no he punched
me first
I could have tequila Tuesday's or Taco
Tuesday yeah that book Rene Garcia bro -
vodka nom - head labrum I put to the
whole set right and never still do a
whole set bro
[Music]
Johnny Thunder he did uh when I started
doing comedy I saw you like on this
little thing on TV can i oh yeah man
that's that thing for him TV Fidesz
we're like I showed you like doing your
day job as a hospital or the Oxford and
after that getting ready for the ha hi
never like I knew what that guy it was
probably the probably should I had ever
done at that moment that it was a that's
a just hit it just hit it was coming out
and they were trying to do all these
promotions you know to promote different
they were doing my promotion think
country yeah you know that's true quick
segment about me follow me it was an all
it was pretty much an all-day thing they
follow me going to work getting dressed
getting dressed going to work leaving
getting going back home getting dressed
and then hitting the club doing the open
mikes and my spots and stuff and it was
actually really cool and even now for
Robles was like man dude because they
show you they show your commercial more
than they show content on on that job
because I've seen it like a million
times before Robles I mean he's working
with a toughy you're paying you guys
paying comments to tweet [ __ ] out yeah
yeah they would send an email hey can
you blast out about this and we'll pay
you like 75 bucks
[ __ ] whatever gift cards gift cards came
in here yeah oh wow super dope but it
was like what are we promoting here I
don't know you know it didn't make sense
oh yeah we there's promoting something
specific nerd
Oh Valentine's Day but it was like
different hashtags and jokes about
Valentine's Day but like what were we
what were we pushing I don't remember
what you know about 6:00 in the morning
drunk but MTV threats was like proto
like like [ __ ] better like or me to
you know before like app there was like
social media for likely a lot people and
then and then I think oh and then Mike
Robles you didn't write
god no comedy yeah I did killer logos in
the local comedy jam so I'm sorry I had
just missed the K logos and then I don't
I did the locals everything yeah so amen
what were they like when you started
robbing and I'm Houston they're Latino
comedians or just sever ones
no there was there wasn't a lot that
couldn't crews out there right right but
but I think when I started I think
that's when Latino comedians were really
starting to get a lot of attention
attention yeah so what we were very much
in the room
Eddy crews different Isis San Antonio
Martinez was running the comedy showcase
it gave me a lot of love there
how much do did the artist was never in
a box he passed away wasn't me Oh Augie
no it was funny it was when he passed
away he was jogging he left us [ __ ]
gonna wait all that what ya man dude and
he was he was actually literally trying
to change his life bro you he was trying
to stop partying drinking and he he
started working out from Texas yeah and
him acquittal Rodriguez man were really
good friends dude and um it was pretty
sad I remember Mike nobly was in San
Antonio why would he pass the hoodie
went to the funeral and I said I [ __ ]
up my role went over the top of this
[ __ ] kilo clothes check what
six months okay my check this day I had
an Anna Chapman rabbit paws throw my
sticks to her eke rest me me yours was a
blank check he was gonna write it huh
yeah man but it was fun dude it was fun
starting there with the time that I did
man there was at the left left or the
just joke in the black Club no no I
might well my first set was that just
joking uh at the black Club as a matter
of fact there was another black Club
that that was before that one that I was
Joe papers before just joking yeah it
was called man it was hosted by Russia
Sean McDonald I remember that and and
and and I mean like all the black
comedians were coming through there and
at the time and one villain real was the
only Latino comic that was getting a lot
of love there and I'll be honest you
know kwangmin the rule I mean could go
up in front of a black Club and just
slay it just lay it wrong and I'm like
oh my god the river people yeah man I
was just like watching this guy just
just do Willie Barcena
you guys ever see the river before
actually walking real and and Joe Garcia
probably somewhere I like did anything
else on that yeah dude what the [ __ ] doc
yeah Mike goes in San Antonio yeah man
hey what's that I Texas community says
the N word a lot flow oh oh and is like
yeah I'm right I saw a special on HBO
and just the N word every time what
though yeah that's just a an
impersonation of one Villarreal and Joe
Garcia you've all been fooled
so without you were like what's our
Latino art in comics look I stay in San
Antonio I think comedians well I'm me
personally I'm biased on Texas comics in
general dude I don't care if they're in
Austin Dallas Valley yeah call it or
tweeting about getting punched by Willie
but the reason one bias is just because
I know what it's like to live there and
travel and and and drive 6 8 10 hours
for $300 I mean that's the grind that we
did you know that in Texas that's what
we dig like a double-edged sword because
you have a lot of work potential but the
gloves know you'll dry ricochetted me to
live it for a while right you could say
I'm a tricky terrorist
in 1996 I was doing the Latino left
festival 25 years ago now that's 20 30
23 years ago 24 know and never met the
guy but he looked he seemed like a lot
of people back there did you like
professionals to me like David the
recorder bro yeah I didn't know like I
would literally he just got a little
sure I don't know I thought you got like
a big show I'm not saying that my show
is big but it was big at the time here
but there's gonna be a letter man no
it's gonna be some work but not man he
was also a diamond in the rough with me
in 1996 Wow at the San Antonio River
Center comedy club I remember man short
hair dog I remember signing autographs
happy first time in a hotel by myself
first time everything bro first time our
TV
first I'm flying really I landed I
caught my Bob from the River Center we
were saline oh yeah man this is not this
is not the time where you went in there
and and rip [ __ ] up right I don't know I
can't remember it was San Antonio
Houston that's how I think it might have
been used in then yeah yeah the hotel
then they kicked y'all out or something
you were with somebody with somebody
else though right yeah I mean cuz I know
it wasn't just you know we got kicked
out with with Edward too but it was in
Tucson
I don't know there Phoenix but no at
that uh he's probably talking about San
Antonio when they when I they keep
somebody out there was party with us
came back and took the television yeah
yeah that's it the airport wait that's
before flat screen so they don't tell
you when they came back they'd even know
that they took in you broken that with a
dirtiest condo ever bro you know that
condo pushes you sit down and then you
need like someone to help you get back
up yeah you sunk right in dude no a no
was only one television right did they
put all the cards in the same yeah
really promising I was in that condo one
time with Gabriel Iglesias
I went Marty Moreno and myself bro and
then I finally said you know what man do
another card or smaller one a little a
little Ray Charles one bro hard-ass
bears don't have lamps in a couple of
those yeah it was
a window with like a miniature
queen-size bed with a big [ __ ] six
five foot window tool chop outside give
up a life dtpa
and I watch television and bathroom and
shower I'd say Oh tiny hey and I slept
there but dog food work man
I even slept on that dirty ass couch I
have a man and I play was the AC was the
only thing I've seen your life brush
you'll go down to 50 but the only thing
that was good in that room cockroaches
the first night there I party so hard
like that I didn't sleep bro and I was
trying to sleep on Saturday morning to
get ready for write but they were having
a fiesta fair outside dog taco
so right after the car dog bands were
playing bro yeah and I couldn't sleep
mariachi bands now whenever you're when
have you heard of quiet mariachi band I
was like so what I did was I went to the
movie theater I told a movie theater
that I'm gonna clean it before next door
and I slept with two boys in them
recline see and I got up and it was a
seven or six o'clock to the comedy club
and I slept there for another forty did
I [ __ ] it to one of the great house
showers very much with a hot towel balls
our pits
everybody knows who do is know what a
great out shower he does who shows that
that party bro slip like a soldier yeah
slip good bro I felt like relieved like
a I never did you supposed to stop for
the next to date equipment can't hydrate
you just relax man
clean man recharge those batteries
you know who you know who was not even
doing comedy at the time when I even
when I started wrong I was already like
three to three years in and he wasn't
even doing comedy at the time he was 19
dustin ybarra bro hey man dustin ybarra
i was doing this to the wind part yes I
I was doing check this out it's funny I
do I was doing a gig up up in Dallas
dude I was doing a hyenas at the time
and I had a DUI so I had a I had a thing
that I had to blow him like my steering
wheel right oh yeah I was drinking I see
blow Roberts up man
Dustin didn't drink at the time he
didn't he didn't do anything bro he's
square and I asked him I say hey man
came to me a favor he goes yeah man
because uh he goes I don't drink though
and I go I know I go I know it's okay
can you blow in this thing in my like I
gotta get back to my hotel room
Dustin's in my car blow to the start my
car bro and I'm [ __ ] him this
passenger side [ __ ] you so need a key
for those or a key oil I don't know is
that your key your air here now duster
bar hit the blue in your car to started
yeah bro just so I could get back to the
hotel enough with DUIs yeah but now it
keeps you have to always like blow into
it like yeah I don't know what the
circumstances are now this is back in
2000 when do you buy used car in the
house it's a stolen car yeah yeah yeah
Jerry Lewis party at all dude let me I'm
gonna be honest you do you know me Luke
over beer what's that
cold beer weed no be back then oh just
drinking man drinking that was my thing
brother I didn't I didn't do blow I
didn't smoke dope I ain't nothing bro I
didn't [ __ ] you really hurt your black
woman though just the act
yeah I used to drink and you were in the
service right
you were the army right no no I wasn't
in the military at all a little dark
test oh yeah well it's my grandparents
yeah
I know but it sounds in the military so
kind of technically I guess but yeah man
good stuff good stuff there Tyler
Warriors lost but wait oh wait it's
still three minutes left
oh are they using right now I'm watching
oh yeah man do so I was uh you know I
think having my son so early dude you
know I didn't really hold you I was I
mean they're probably like 20 20 years
old yeah I remember watching you um I
was out of town and they show you try
you try enough for Last Comic Standing
oh yeah it was you came on television
was it that the same year you yeah yeah
and um and and now you did a total about
the Charles Lynch Waldo got it and then
a touch with a girl sitting like it'll
pay child support
like never look like it's a joke yeah
dude that's a hard addition to follow
yeah she she didn't like it at all from
your early at least you got on your
first time it was it was dope how many
more [ __ ] girls called you Oh what and
yeah a lot a lot dude yeah even even
people when I went to the hospital they
were like hey man I was watching that
that comedy show last night if they go
you do you do stand-up there was a guy
look just like yeah man dude it was it
was dope a season you know hey you know
who got me through the line I went there
just to show up bro no no you know you
don't know you hit Rita you didn't have
an audition so yeah readeth what's up
dude Rita saw me in line she goes what
are you doing we better manager that
Hollywood yeah I'm proud dude and she
goes oh my
she's throat ampion products people yeah
she told me to hold on a second she went
up came right
that you put on you layer is oh yeah man
you yeah yeah and you know what and so
she got me in and she goes hey she goes
I got Union she goes no the rest is up
to you she goes go do what you do and I
just that's why I went in there and that
was the first joke I said man when you
at that little when you were talking to
the host Gerardo and Nicky and yeah
after you you you got off they tell you
that they were gonna show you did you
sign paper right away what they say
didn't tell me nothing they just they
just told me to sign the paper
all right so you know they were gonna
show you yeah well they didn't say that
they were but the guys were like hey we
need you to sign it because in case that
we show you he goes we have to have you
sign this and I go okay cool I didn't
but I didn't know that I was gonna come
out I did not know that
well we're not we're never not due to
audition I didn't even watch it well
it's worth this [ __ ]
I rolled out I left my [ __ ] through the
road I saw the door either right my
beach cruiser cuz I rode a bicycle over
there so as soon as I got past it
started interviewing me and yeah but
what are you gonna do if you didn't made
it through
same thing I'm doing right now I'll
change my bike going holding right down
through the sunset right that's what
made I'm excited but he's our bicycle
story dude
I picked you up that there's your story
right and then the baikonur are old
enough to drive my truck and close your
bike on my truck and it just like oh you
roll up the skateboards how you driving
rubbery this guy is always the right
spell right his game dejoy Medina Hood
audition so he was getting close and I
told him what same thing but you're
gonna have to be little too interesting
bro yeah yeah I was at my high cancer
I never break up a cancer story
something of the [ __ ] my mother late
he was just thrown a bunch of those died
I was gonna say man I'm glad he didn't
do anything sexually perverted like
George is fairly broke I'm gonna podcast
and I called him on that one time he
went to this he was doing a show
somewhere in Arizona they were having
like a advertisement party and all the
every time they were there like a lady
from combat everybody and therefore what
spokespeople spokespeople he was you
have room and let the Sharpie he was
signing his consent with by the way cuz
that's it yes
and now we go these right Memorex keep
kids ruler happy you've been a happy
face and a little finger okay it was a
boat ah I remember that anyway let's
have people here with a ziplock be a
finger yeah no touchy jigs at the club
you want to go on a date with me and my
friend because you can't prove it it's
like sandy or Wilson from home
improvement measured out was a fast
batter something you today bro what
George Lopez is hosting the Jazz
Festival
no um what's-her-name was performing on
the coup in the gang
oh and she lay chili yeah she's badass
right here parading mom over G
upholstery I would never known he said
that after read she's the reason he
plays timbale Stromboli's bro
why
Bali's anybody timbale welcome to that
I'll tell you the madman where were you
born
cuz he's not that all bro East are you
gotta be this guy's age right no I don't
mind
whoo how do you learn 30 ok cool again
there's no coos and hang out with gangs
when I started playing the bass yeah
it's funny well you know someone for a
long time that you see a post op teen
you know like starting his own life
somewhere else you know friend your old
buddy you company [ __ ] I didn't want you
to comment yeah but they want everybody
else to be funny I blocked that
[ __ ] dude that was terrible some
food let's get the full Cisco he went to
crossing again he went to Boston
everywhere and he took the picture here
outside Cheers
and I wrote another play nobody knows
who you are
the way those your name you're breaking
the the facade that they've created
[ __ ] you know me for [ __ ] you talkin
[ __ ] to him on Twitter saying he was the
first comedian Vietnam now you wear that
did he have a microphone no no no this
was this is when it happened I I but I
never I don't think he even told me the
name but he was just like yeah man these
fools are hating your oh oh yeah and I
was like oh what happened I was like
What did he say
he's like you
nobody anything you're supposed to like
she had to go to the ER opacity show me
a picture of like girls going down I
know look at it what are you telling the
story right now that's cool wait maybe
take pictures of polar's I don't know
your son it's not like Momo run
everybody
mungus dog bite you oh wow so every turn
Willian whatever right he's so [ __ ]
ugly dogs with my bro
you know work with Willie your chick in
the road yeah I never on the road but I
never went to his house yeah yeah and a
restaurant for for 90% of the time I
that I've ever known really he's always
been cool to me he's never really other
than the other 10% that I can remember
but I mean the guys you know we're all
drunk hammered you know talking [ __ ] you
know no big deal
I'm the newer guy yeah you know but you
know for the 90% dude he was totally
[ __ ] cool with me dude no I never
really I like people from Houston bro
yeah bro dude I remember [ __ ] the
first time that I opened up for Willie
wasn't Houston I was still living there
at the time and we had a badass [ __ ]
night bro it was a Thursday night Larry
Omaha was the world's jacket yeah yeah
Larry Omaha was featuring and Willie I
want to go out to a club tonight man
it'd be this would chuck Bartowski
we I take him to one of the hottest
spots in Houston bro on a Thursday it's
a salsa club bro it's a salsa club you
said yeah I knew I was gonna get I know
it's gonna get a Willie side man casino
here and that's why they're gonna win
the rest of the game yeah so anyway so
we get there we're having a great time
I'm not gonna bubble know it about 20
minutes in I get a phone call from my
end your aunt my aunt and tells me that
my grandmother just died oh yeah my
demeanor done changed and and Willie
goes April it goes what's the matter
with you man and I go hey man I go I'm
sorry do my it's got a phone call that
my my grandmother just passed away he
goes oh it's a buzz killer bro I'll see
you later bro took off don't be a
buzzkill
I can read people bro I couldn't do
anything
wait Wow would you bro dude I was so sad
you know what but that was so funny I
Lavrov was that the last day of the road
or did you set more days than them no it
was just used to that was it rough we
shall have to happen you just think of
joy Medina's
[Music]
because I think Larry was telling me
that he was you know so you know you
know like girls for dick my humongous it
takes two selfies
and you grab Rob spaghetti one time but
I was like seven and my mom left me in
the house alone and I like tried to cook
it on the fire he wants to charge me
rent for the closet
the judo Ruffy man who stood on yeah
yeah I did we started yeah I was there
for about 97 98 9 and yeah so I was
already going on my fourth year I guess
and then that's when he moved to LA to
do less Comic Standing and you know
[ __ ] the rest is history for that guy
man he just blew the [ __ ] up bro but
yeah man I came up at a good time man a
lot of guys were there like that were
we're hot at the time and Doug Stanhope
was always going through there so cool
Joe Rogan was going through there of
course he was going through a lot back
there Jeff Garcia was going I discovered
this photo was coming there pretty so
yeah man you look funny with the most
besides Willie he'll probably bring it
in heat huh yeah and of course column
and see Angelo people just selling out
every time problem always they're always
selling out right George George problem
is eh me see a Georgia Mencia where
Solomon everywhere yeah
Paul was was still coming in but not as
much he wasn't coming as much as as
Carlos in and George were bro in 1998 no
in 1998 I [ __ ] uh I open bro for gene
pompa he was a minutes to Lima color
with featuring they flew me out bro and
had a room but back then when they were
paying yo ass
so maybe 325 to host and he flew me out
and yeah and I'm suiting McCullough he
[ __ ] drove here a badass 1985 Bronco
blue one oh wow he drove over himself
bro and I hit five cases of you know
your mama you know you get away of books
Oh guess all the balls sold of all and
then people she has more shipped to him
but yeah man I was man that's old school
opening Humphrey so when I was talking
to their Mike Bernal the manager back
then he was a manager of the punch of
post neck Sacramento yeah he told me
that I'm George Lopez economist here
they compete with each other to sell out
more short or add more shows
never surprised me no the top your back
then they were always selling up yeah
because I would say Pablo and Freddy
Soto were probably like right under that
the world Commons they talk [ __ ] you
know like oh he's done he's done
nah he's been headlining since I started
so I don't know man you just starting
he's to headline is here you're not here
like these guys were hit Pablo I watched
Empire I probably was sweating in a
special or they were saying he's done
but that for being here ladies and I
starting ever never doing is coming for
worse 25 years no 20 easy so these guys
with headlines as I started there's to
hell I mean these guys talking [ __ ] on
us to not even opening I know I just saw
Pablo uh i sounds like a couple of weeks
ago man
he was headlining I was like I didn't
even know he was here I was like I went
over there say hello to the picture as a
person and I watched like I can watch
the ice house I watched probably like
ten minutes before I had to go and do my
spot but the ten minutes he was
murdering like back like in 97-98 for
like murdering and I mean the crowd is
just like I mean he and he still has
that energy
the voice is everything bro
Pablo it's time to get up yeah what's up
much of res over there still thinking
about Jordan of penis diapers of him
writing and [ __ ] like [ __ ] your Flash
Gordon a horse huh he's taken intestines
what the crazy to you ditching his leg
and family to her so CUDA and I remember
I made a bunch of CDs bootleg CDs what
have you done to get by whatever you saw
so I saw shirts
I never seen with Murch I I sold shirts
years ago
I first started and I started saying
he's the first shirt I sold the it said
all it said was a white t-shirt with
blue trimming fitted and all that said
was dope puto on it hurts all it said
which is basically slang especially in
Texas just means like you know like like
how George Lopez says you know mas puto
well that was our esto puto and but it
was truly in Texas and because almost
because I was only mainly doing gigs in
Texas what I was selling shirts like
running hiking rock spirit a the
comedian runner you guys seen a [ __ ]
rainbow northa lately all of his bluff
he looks like a walking photoshop
vitamin business and kind of weird yeah
I work with him I work with him mom last
year is buff but last Valentine's Day
today she's like I'm not saying that but
it's just weird buff know that time I
saw him and he was like taking
supplements and I'm doing those vitamins
well he has a gout [ __ ] up that's what
he said he I started jomi Deena [ __ ]
suffers from God to use a couple more
that [ __ ] hurts me because I ran I don't
feel real I know that steroids bro it's
like oh that's like with Jesus huh with
the [ __ ] lightning ball that's weird
that's in it looks like a fat dog you
can't just declare it
[ __ ] monsters punching holes in the
wall [ __ ]
him and Willie wrestle match dude I
remember when noe Gonzales equally for
Carlos Mencia and this is the whole body
though you know what fools was a bunch
of wait to see what you look like after
the babies got hips yeah skinny prison
legs you skipping that what you're
saying is skipping like Dwight Yoakam I
saw the foolin shorts they got a tenner
there wait
yeah what's up fools how long your
stand-up career did you start headlining
oh gosh probably every text article they
saw a head like me in tour in six months
right yeah they start headlining and
then they start feature and then they
start opening well [ __ ] planet is
YouTube you wanna know what gamers
worries I mean have you recorded you buy
the worst threat no doubt cristela
Alonzo told me that out that she was
doing a stable time and it's a oh no
rule I guess it takes it to me to do
that again Lonnie she [ __ ] said that
out she was doing her said a rickety
repeater her setlist I know by her
notebook you know her notebook oh those
am I gonna find a job that she was
saying and it was tagging am RP and she
knew was hello or hipster because that
Dino correcting eggs
come on man you don't do that right well
I'll give you like a person oh yeah no I
was talking to the tape recorder but I
left a trail I was to record right next
to me you're Bobby hey dude good you're
conscious yeah I don't think he's ever
done that with me and now he's giving me
advice you need to give him a tic-tac
yeah game there you play with the
numbers no Dooku Sudoku boy so dope yeah
Tito method no Freddie Mega Man he just
came out to me away from Jonah Hill was
drying the deck huh I usually do that in
middle school me my friend used to dry
up in a book I wrote we see God gigs and
my teacher she grabbed my notebook is
she was like what is this and she was
like I need to talk to you after school
so I was supposed to meet after school
and I was scared it's like [ __ ] I drew a
bunch of dicks and you're my friend you
were drawing dicks on the magazines you
know yes so then I think she was going
through a divorce cuz she was like not
there so when I after school she went to
those teachers i wonder they just doing
this i took the notebook I threw away
and I ran and
I sort of got that it was like in 1999
bro eight years before super bad bro we
have a serial zero and then go boy oh my
god no rickety is genetic you know you
do a tic-tac-toe you do the line late
you're doing tic-tac-toe like what a
brainstorm at 9:39 there nine squares so
Rick was saying that um you have to do
like five minutes query five minute at
me square on one top and is 45 dogs here
there's a [ __ ] outside so you thana
forward on stage and then I guess Pablo
saw a little bit right he walked away
and then Rick told out gay bro woody
stately sanity
yo man he's very familiar but will you
put his head up dog
I will never saw him down yeah there's
this [ __ ] yeah anybody was paying
anything to make him feel bad yeah yeah
told me that right after a killer set
and there's always that that I would say
man you know what Maddie wants a this
dude but go to my bag there's a brand
new bag a COAG a bro take it
[Laughter]
you're done with the payments yeah my
kids 24 bro nobody was more happier than
me when that [ __ ] was coming to an end
and nobody was more sad than my [ __ ]
ex-wife had I mean literally it was just
we were going in to our opposite
directions and it feels fantastic and
that's why when I hear like other
comedians are you know just people that
I know that I work with maybe that are
going through this [ __ ] and they got the
kids were 5 7 3 2 and I'm like man you
got all [ __ ] way to go brother and I
said feel sorry for you but get ready
for [ __ ] even worse hell than you
you're [ __ ] already going through
right now dude I go cuz it's gonna get
[ __ ] worse the best times the best
thing you talk somebody even on the
minute listen bro you guys gotta be nice
well I'm gonna get ugly dog [ __ ] that
I'd be Rikku Tierra's on my familiar
they start telling me their sad stories
I was not not [ __ ] the one you miss
yeah Kelly swinging or somebody else
oh man dusty brown or brown dirty white
guy black dude Oh black guy Hamburg
Daryl Heath no no no you're the wife
heal you but no or smokey bring up
Smokey the Bear
oh uh smokey D's smokey yeah yeah like
his wife would leave you know somebody
would leave in his ass
you have man I was smoking a joint and
then I said you know he's gonna go up
right to the hotel vows to you I said
Arlo records I could have kept the $50
right we don't go up yeah yeah yeah no
to your name well just walk that I want
loaded bro and hopefully it DUI another
time bro I was party was a guy a guy
came to go party with us hang out with
us at Walker Yogi's and then the last
time I saw him was a New York on a roll
that fool was starting that forward to
Willie Barcena house and got more loaded
and spent the night but that fool told
me this crazy story brother that was
scared later on he was hey Sonu from
Arizona New York I go how was that party
in New York and guess who walked in he
said who man [ __ ] Sammy the bull
Gravano whole bunch of white kids you
know bunch of crazy [ __ ]
and what'd you do that bro I got next to
a form right took over it just to in
five minutes five minutes but the whole
story of send a story browse over bro no
drugs
yeah yeah yeah oh like stink
didn't go home and if your wife or his
chick left on bro oh [ __ ]
damn yeah no you kill roaches bro nobody
cared
hey bro what did you want to be Doug the
security guard bro or a comedian bro
no get a good night's sleep next to the
two by four oh four bro like a pitbull
man did you see those videos of him
wrestling his son more recent right yeah
oh yeah it's real bros crazy well I
think it's all red-faced yeah you have
dates coming up uh yeah actually I'm
gonna be in Phoenix at the house of
comedy at the end of the month
Rick Bronson every brother bro what's
that you look a young rig bro yeah
Ricardo Bronson really record although
you don't have no he's cool I mean I
I've seen pictures of brittle joint he
really Martin he has a Phoenix yeah yeah
I mean yeah it's in Phoenix yeah because
the last time I was there I was there
with Kate Quigley
and he he was there actually yeah and we
seen over the car oh really
yeah we saw him also when we were in
Canada yeah up cheerio Club he's too
close you're at the Edmonton Edmonton
yeah you can't go to Canada if you have
a DUI
no yet a pay yeah you it'll cost you the
same money you make that you go there
see we just make merch yeah but they're
waiting for you yeah yeah any money no
do it every time and they love American
comedians that's the reason he opened up
the clubs could go because the the
competing clubs then the only book local
comedians like an alien's but they want
to see Americans grateful dog yeah every
comedian it's the fire
it's like performing somewhere for the
first time or letting in a moon whatever
we were you from these they all make
like you put that Cali flavor away
Cali well yeah I want to feel like I've
been high enough where I thought I was
on the moon and I like that experience
bro so I want to go with that when
people turn up like right do jokes on
but I'm like a little message board like
homie in the head looks like he pees
when he laughs hard and it not even
funny moment it do you Daniel Daniel
you're the kind of guy that puts his
pants down puts a mirror on the floor
and jerks off while watching his own ass
you're gonna come up with comments
but when they're all unfunny uncreated
coffee kind of late he was so touchy
touchy crowd lately as far as PC oh you
know you know yeah or anybody told you
man with your [ __ ] they used to have
yeah man sorry I know I guess [ __ ] like
that all the time bro only now Leigh how
was some of your love for Astros as soon
as that why look no one else cares out
but only does yeah and I know it's good
and and and and I know it's gonna give
me [ __ ] but I I just don't give a [ __ ]
anymore and I'm like you know I didn't
come here to [ __ ] talk about the
Astros it's just a hat that I'm [ __ ]
where I don't write yeah you wanna talk
about the Astros you wanna [ __ ] you what
you want me to tell jokes Maggie laughs
you know what I mean and then it's my
only way that I go okay let's get off of
that [ __ ] and I'm not here to [ __ ]
indulge in this [ __ ] let's just do let
me do my [ __ ] [ __ ] and trust me
you're gonna laugh and have a good time
and then we're all gonna [ __ ] do blow
out to the [ __ ] show if I can get
down all right [ __ ] let's have a good
time right and these guys man well fool
Huston
yo suck I'm like I have to do a promo
today I just do a promo for Chicago and
I'm gonna do with my this juror and Ally
hat and beyond for primer for promos
right but one of them I just wonder
whether Ally had a I'm coming to a late
but they're want people to come if you
know bro take these ahead and hold me or
some other [ __ ] yeah this issue at
that but then you carving on them like
you call me not know you comment on them
and they [ __ ] out right away I was only
kidding me Edward oh yeah I called your
it and you push it out with your big
[ __ ] man control dude keyboard warrior
yeah man I mean I get it you know
Detroit bro yeah I mean you know it's
but it's it's it's nothing different
then after we get past it and then the
show goes on and then you know I do i do
my [ __ ] we get down and then they want
to [ __ ] buy me a drink
well you know what I'm gonna let you buy
me a [ __ ] drink but I'm not gonna
talk to you you know what I mean I'm
gonna take the [ __ ] drink I'm not
stupid
I have Latino you think yeah but I'm not
gonna see you here and then just try to
be your best friend [ __ ] all that man
yeah cuz because they you're right dude
they they do come at you man if I can
give you [ __ ] like dude and then they
after and then after the show they
[ __ ] want to be your friend and I
help you Christmas eka yeah man
you jus like push him around all that
[ __ ] I had the fortunate of you know
you're open with him that I didn't have
to do that
oh sure oh yeah bro but I you know I
remember I realized shows with him yeah
I remember came broke a loafer to me was
working with him and I for was loaded
bro like passed out and for the night
before right late whatever he gets
[ __ ] up back then he opened up the
wheelchair and he opened up the seat
part others though the way you sit on it
slaps yeah yeah he had it face too close
to it when they opened although few I
don't know what's worse that or rig
Gutierrez brazzers he has colostomy this
guy with joy Medina's dick poor guy who
whoever policy pretty has it together in
the room I remember I dropped it off I
dropped him off and he was to party in
there and he am his dumb room look like
I told later went through it but it was
but it was everything was close to love
like if you could pack it oh yeah yeah I
guess oh I thought your room yeah that
means Christmas egg is doing really well
Newburgh I want to hear something crazy
I was just recently in Portland doing
Harvey's with Manny Maldonado and this
is how crazy this is man this was last
year actually or was it last year or I
don't remember you guys what you guys
will know and we're looking up at the
the things like this in the in the green
room and there's an old there's an old
picture up of King Lopez of when he he
headline there right and at Harveys
comedy club in Portland and I said to I
go look at that man is king Lopez in it
man he's like
[ __ ] man isn't that weird like you know
we start talking about Cain and blah
blah blah blah and we were talking about
how him in Siddiqui were really good
friends and you're a buzzkill bro
passing away the next day is when we got
a text message from Manny in the morning
dude you're good this is gonna be crazy
goes by [ __ ] Siddiqui died man he
goes look at your you're feeding your
facebook about that one message are you
still alive just checking were you
around when everyone thought on his John
died yes sorry Denver Colorado before
sick on stage okay and then those are
Camila back there and a local community
whenever a Latino comedian I forgot his
name he helped him write yeah and then
like that foo called up Ernie Jian told
him did he change the story change after
him then I heard he died the grapevine
what color I called everybody he died
haha Terry Terry said oh my god you sure
because here this by 9:30 I use that
escape your father's room it started out
with with artist John just going to CBS
I love his answering machine Laura's a
man I really hope you didn't die
everyday that is for me call me we
didn't say later that I was people
calling me for get on the road John John
for only one time here when I drove to
right regardless or the way to Blythe
bro like the supposed to be there at a
theater at 9:30
oh my god we were lost for here to a
[ __ ] up Toyota they had 13 I worked on
a Toyota was the [ __ ] of cigarette
lighter there was no radio I don't know
sounds moved back then yeah so I know
what to do but you know nasty my voice
for the show I have a sore throat so
don't know talking I know I fall asleep
my old lost we woke up and then for me
the wrong turn bro like you go take a
bite like eight and it took some other
freeway and then we saw like a Coke
machine like five country fools like my
redneck guys they weren't wearing white
hoods white hats and we spoke to them
you go would you guys going with to
accomplish our lives what's your name is
Felipe and then Honest John
my name is Arliss - that's all this Hank
this is all this Bill Nye abolish all
this Abe always hang who's dead
I love it rosana's do you say nothing to
them bro you just turn around sadness or
throw bro obviously he's like a wrestler
named Honest John we get to Brod little
black [ __ ] bro
you know throw black shirt that name
sounds good I worked on stage he was
like he would have thought that they
never said oh yeah okay I don't think
I've ever seen that problem okay I'm
throwing what time I had no completing
the Walker Yoda he left who showed up
and I say man I think possibly didn't
show up but you want to go up and do 15
really all right man give me five minute
I'm a look at my thumb when you think
you would wear it I really might be
hooked up that night with a key [ __ ]
the gap that night where was a chick
inside he some maybe guys he went in
some car with somebody right there was
another job does it there's a table full
of Navy guys let's do it just hanging
out right and I guess I'm gonna get
shipped out but they were just hanging
out and one of the Navy guys went inside
a car with her black shirt and it was
like a big dumb brunette your style
right you [ __ ] the grower guy knows
world oh girl they wouldn't send with a
girl but no but I sure say he left why'd
you leave all manly my father took all
his clothes off in the car can't oh I
think you want to put it past enough for
he took all his clothes out I said but
it was it was in the Navy yeah though he
took all his clothes and folding them
and put it to the side and then look
they looked alike all right ready
so he put he pulled this on it is nice
we know everything boy [ __ ] you little
badge ha ha ha sorry ass you even took
off his class
well he wanted he was looking for a
hanger for the gentleman no you should
work on stage I know he'll be okay how
you gonna wear a thong on stage and then
be so proper with your [ __ ] expects
so sort of freaky oh yeah she just
psycho on him bro no no I got I met this
chick one time brothers-in-law yeah she
came over I opened up that notebook shed
a notebook am I on my father were in
that notebook bro like a little girl
from [ __ ] Tiger Beat yeah Donny
Osmond bro and then I said a folder for
that and a folder from Somalia for
everything she like back in the days
right and then like never know that
David I was gonna show you the world's
crack yeah yeah yeah yeah bro oh man
that meant that night I remember that
night because I [ __ ] know that gather
wood that I kidnapped brought took with
me why boy you you know hook you know
where that girl later on right yeah and
all she would do was talk about him what
she oh yeah yeah groupie huh yeah yeah
I'm gonna drive to San Antonio and pick
him up and we're Houston and then we're
gonna drive back and she's telling me
I'm like I know who the [ __ ] she was I
was doing a gig in a bar with it was me
who early two-thousands like
I knew it was early 2000 because I
didn't move into a move to LA to to
doesn't sing you were livin way before
that yeah I was Texas still good Dutch
man shut up - Eddie Cruz you looking for
that sure Oh miss my flight so Mel what
the [ __ ] I do know those I miss my
flight but I didn't join up late Pete
pick me up bro oh there is a win Oh Pete
pallet beat yeah Pete pretty off pretty
poor people ready the owner right and
now he picked me I never forget that
that awareness I don't like always a new
black roll over black sweats a black
sweatshirt and I had a just of a
backpack full of dirty clothes and then
I had this time I had no socks and I was
like with no socks for the last two days
I've been up yeah yeah and I'll perform
that that Hey look at me like I'm gonna
make the whole week tell me that one
show you do you were in the same socks
forever and you're sliding so your shoes
yeah like they work Eddie was telling me
that story what story
no he was telling me about a man he goes
uh because you know Felipe was supposed
to do this show man and I showed up
really late baba and I was like oh I go
was he wasn't he coming from San Antonio
yeah could then this chick was telling
me about it there's a cycle dude we dude
I hooked up with a couple of times right
and then I don't know what happened she
started this is when well I think those
myspace came out yeah dude she was I
took uh I took a picture with my
girlfriend at the time because I had a
girlfriend
you keep talking about Felipe count
Donna when they were- be in the back in
San Antonio yeah but do I think it is
because I lived there she I live I lived
in Houston and I mean serotonin is like
right up the [ __ ] Street you know what
I mean I mean it's technically three and
a half hours but when you live doing
that right yeah yeah that Drive that's
that's that drives [ __ ] nothing it's
all straight
yeah it is oh he also turns straight
flat is [ __ ] dude
yeah man you just in your San Antonio
and let those all like yeah he's cool
man
yeah dude haven't seen that in a long
time so he stole his wife yeah man just
really said you're a party pooper I'll
tell you man you go back to it rule yeah
you guys who reads the Bible here's
whatever he does real I don't know man
you know he is so funny dude well I mean
I haven't seen him in a long time but
you know at the time when we were like
doing a lot of shows together man he was
so [ __ ] funny he was just the nicest
guy ever never really wanted to say
anything bad and when he did say
something bad about somebody he felt
[ __ ] guilty you know he was that guy
you know I mean like you would like it
would it would overcome him and he would
see we just [ __ ] say it but then he'd
like feel bad and then he [ __ ] go you
know don't go to confession you know and
[ __ ] like that because these people felt
so bad I'm like dude don't worry about
it I get it you know I mean you [ __ ] the
guy pissed you off you know it's [ __ ]
vent bro like event it's okay to vent
yeah man at this guy features with me
there in San Antonio and forgotten it
Richard or something
Oh Richard and that we couldn't give
we're giving us he couldn't get weed or
drugs are weak and suppose the last time
you and I kind of work together and I
give you a chance to feature you can you
produce what kind of question guy to you
though how did you know [ __ ] back there
bro I feel like your comedy should just
be above everything bro yeah you're
gonna make the person that hooked you up
happy yeah and you know what back then
now that I know now
you realize master some comics they're
not gonna thank you on the road or
they're not gonna let you work with them
because you're pressuring that your
personality doesn't go with me you know
somebody on the road gonna call me I
want you to [ __ ] outdo me now let's
show you you can you know it's amazing
how I used to be back then as opposed to
what I am now bro oh no no my only vice
was drinking my own my only vice was
rival because I I never I never I never
was except I never was accepted no no I
wasn't around I wasn't around people who
did blow and maybe there was a lot of
guys at that smoked the dough but that
wasn't my thing I [ __ ] was high school
to me I wanna [ __ ] what is this let's
get some more of that
well you smoke weed remove smoke with
that cop once in a while you know you're
about the powder more though yeah you
did coke yeah I know you did coke but
you started that either you started
blasting it out here though right yeah
man which I just barely started doing
this [ __ ] three four years ago man so I
mean you know it is what it is bro I'm
not you know everybody who they like to
work Portland for the first time because
I've been here before it was nice the
first time Oh to Portland your rv's I
love [ __ ] nice I love that
[ __ ] place man
it's a place that I would I don't know
if I could live there I don't know if I
could live there but I love going to
notice how there's normal people living
in the [ __ ] streets bro like normal
people who are dirty design [ __ ] give
up you just have a gym membership take a
shower there yeah
broke up the [ __ ] Hawaii it was a
JetBlue I'm a living Joey's did yeah
well yeah I do and then I also do
Bronson's at the end of the month I'll
be there so please come check me out
there I by the way I just did another
documentary about myself
Martinez attack you Martinez what does
that with the bowling alley in Dhoni oh
yeah yeah yeah whatever that guy is he
still living in LA Long Beach Long Beach
Rick Pitino's actually started Latino
comedy and that was the Improv and all
is that right Hollywood yeah oh okay
yeah because then it was he started when
I was a man Richard Richard is a bad
word no he started tonight with a with a
female comedy back into these jewel a
Filipino latina it needs to be real
tight I don't hold on oh yeah I haven't
seen her in a long and
ya know before that I remember her yeah
she's actually pretty pretty funny dude
she's not doing comedy anymore I think
she's like in the Christian circuit or
something or like this hanging out with
Gloria never make any I reach it to me
but just a video of Steve Trevino with
him yeah yeah yeah yeah actually I met
Steve when he was just starting to
feature for Carlos yeah cuz i humored
yeah he was headlining like little
one-nighters there in Texas when I was
still living there yeah and I mean at
the time I didn't know he was I just met
the guy was like man this guy's [ __ ]
hilarious you know and I mean you know
we move here and then you know he's on
the [ __ ] road with Carlos and he's
blowing up because of the whole Carlos
and you know starting [ __ ] man I was
like damn man this guy's [ __ ] caught
fire and I mean [ __ ] I mean he was a
former Texas guy and I was like man and
like I said dude I always had [ __ ]
love for Texas comics dude because I
just know the [ __ ] grind I know what
it's I know what it's [ __ ] like to do
[ __ ] gigs for [ __ ] 250 bucks 300
bucks and I'm like man dude but you know
I said I really I really like the fact
that least that Steve was doing well man
if you're a Texas comedian you come out
here and you go back there people you
know you came out to our lay man but if
you live in LA and you just quit to
everybody else who knows you is that you
never tried could you live here though
you bro you go back bro you keep up dawg
you guys see what state [ __ ]
bro you little Texas bro they see you
like broad you were too late thought you
did it though yeah bro I used to tell
comics all the time I'm so glad I don't
I didn't start comedy in LA cuz they get
treated like [ __ ] well it's hard man
it's it's hard for people that moved
from somewhere else cuz you got a try if
now you got to move back my family lives
here man
though the comedian and I feel like
effect
a man I'm picking the moving from our
land oh yeah
and then [ __ ] give up yeah oh [ __ ]
[Laughter]
what do you want to do Rene what's your
is your focus just comedy do you see
yourself like hopefully getting a sitcom
like what see uh well I've been doing
acting I've done a couple of commercials
already which is really nice though I
did this one called M Taylor which was
also it was on shark tank and the guy
one of the guys bought it I think it was
Cuban
they gave him money they and they gave
him money to do commercials and I got
booked for one of them
I did that one and there was another
small one that I think that was also on
shark tank I can't remember the name of
the stupid product anyway really small
commercials but I know but but yeah I'm
trying to do more acting I don't I don't
really care about specifically about
having my own show and I just want to be
successful enough where I'm not having
to [ __ ] grind this [ __ ] about going
to the hospital in the morning [ __ ]
making sure that I come back home in
enough time now making sure I don't get
too [ __ ] drunk making sure I don't
get too coked up I gotta be at work
I'm [ __ ] exhausted Lisa doing it I
really am I just want to get to a cocoa
sometimes it helps I just want to get to
the point where I I can just do
entertainment no matter what it is
whether it's go how much soups but no
I've never done cruise ships never done
that [ __ ] money bro what's up fool
San Jose we moved the San Jose we moved
the San Jose Show to the Emperor of San
Jose improv August 16th to the 18th
there will not be a show June 14 at the
San Jose Civic Center you can get a full
refund wherever you bought your tickets
San Jose improv taking should be on sale
very soon so look out for that man
August 16 to the 18 my bad
New York City June 22 or 23 at
Caroline's on Broadway Atlanta Georgia
June 28th to the 30th at the punchline
Houston Texas June 5th through the 7th
at the Houston Improv Chicago July 13 at
the big theater Tucson July 28 sawatya
desert diamond casino people are tickets
and days listed on political world calm
slash tour some dates through the end of
December - yeah we have a lot of dates
that we're gonna mention later on in the
future but too rich to do your podcast
yes me my girlfriend it was a call
squad by the Bell it's a stupid name
why for the party life of the party yes
I do I have a podcast yes it's uh it's
at turns no brakes it's a all NASCAR
podcast that's right I am a NASCAR dude
man rubber band I do a NASCAR podcast
it's called alternate or less that's
right bro yeah tomorrow if you're
watching live tomorrow
Riverside Spanish show and also next
Wednesday will do the live part yet
again Wednesday we're not going live
Wednesday we're doing another podcast
for next week Yosuke cord Gina Brianna
Santos giggle oh man
it's a Twitter Instagram was so [ __ ]
got tomorrow Riverside Spanish espanol
puto